[Music]
no rent no utilities but a roof over
their head while a housing crisis is
underway here in southern nevada some
landlords are now dealing with squatters
the i-team's vanessa murphy digs deeper
into the issue and has a story the
i-team worked on and how it took a turn
you don't have any information to pay
who do we pay the i-t met this woman at
an apartment near karen and paradise
main problem is getting stuff fixed she
says she has lived here for years and a
new company took over which was trying
to evict her i didn't get the
opportunity to even pay rent with the
new company
they
just gave us notices he just wanted them
to fill it up with dirt she also showed
us these conditions this is the hole
that's been here for about
probably about six to eight months the
i-team called the pala group which
manages the property owner jared
richards told us this woman's a squatter
the company has been trying to remove so
this can be renovated they stayed there
connected power to the
ran cords to run power to them to the
laundry room and just live there
for free for a few years richards owns
and manages multiple properties
throughout the las vegas valley and says
squatters are a frequent problem they
kind of watch it for a while they notice
that there's no activity there and then
they just come in here and they
basically hide out for a certain amount
of time until they get removed he says
that used to be an easier process if you
found somebody in the unit you'd call
the police they'd get them out but now
he says some squatters are presenting
fake leases with their names on them
what happens a lot of times people will
go in and if the police come in and say
this person presents a lease you have to
go through the full eviction process
some of these squatters can get two or
three months out of a property suzy
vasquez is the executive director of the
nevada state department association
unfortunately you know people have
learned how to get around the system how
they're getting up there i don't know
richards took the i-team inside another
property near mccarran airport which he
says had been taken over by squatters
probably just passed drugs back and
forth through here his team is now
cleaning it up the toilets are destroyed
the
countertops they smoke and set their put
their cigarettes out on them and you
know they burn the carpet they
defecate on the floor richard says once
this property was re-secured so door
bolted shut windows boarded up squatters
started coming through the roof it's
extremely frustrating it makes our job
very hard he says a family with children
lives next door another reason what
unfolded here was a problem when they
clean this out tons of needles
you know
lots of drug paraphernalia he estimates
damages to one unit alone at 15 thousand
dollars there's nothing salvageable
about it vanessa murphy live local now
in some instances tenants may not know
they are technically squatters some
scammers rent out properties that are
not theirs by again using fake leases